make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys to the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and a
lot of you guys have requested that I
make a video on astral regulator Thanos
specifically like the like a beyond
Omega level video and honestly I didn't
know who that like I don't know what
version of fan O's that was because if
I'm being honest with you guys I have
not really followed jim Starlin infinity
saga after the events of like infinity
crusade right like I finished that and I
was kind of like okay cool I'm kind of
done and that was that was basically it
I know he's written a lot right like
infinity siblings and and infinity
revelations and infinity relativity and
all that I know he's done all that and
we'll go back and cover those things
because some of those stories are cool
others are not but I think it'd be kind
of cool to just sort of have the whole
infinity series on my channel so we'll
probably cover like relativity your
revelations or something like that after
this but you know I I sat down and I was
like okay what in the heck is astral
Regulator Thanos and I looked it up and
I was like okay so like I have to cover
this story because this story's kind of
nuts right now here's the funny thing
about it as I understand it this is what
the Thanos wins story was originally
intended to be by jim Starlin right he
was the one who wanted to write it that
when Donnie Cates wrote that story jim
Starlin wanted to be the one to create
it because jim Starlin was the one that
did so much with the character of
phantom so the result of this is that as
we know Santos twins was a story that
was written you know by Donnie Cates and
so eventually Marvel ended up releasing
this and if I'm being honest with you
guys there's good things about this
story and things that I wasn't really
huge on but it was the same thing with
Thanos winds right there were things
that I loved about it things I didn't
really that I wasn't too big on it I
think if both of these stories were
combined it would be amazing it would be
absolutely ridiculously good because of
all the things that go down here right
for the ways this kicks off is we
initially pick up with Thanos meeting
with Adam warlock now this comes hot off
the heels of Infinity Gauntlet is really
where this little segment of this story
comes from in this sense that those of
you guys who followed my series on
infinity called and infinity war and if
you didn't you'll find both those down
in the description Infinity Gauntlet of
course as most of you guys know is a
story where Thanos discovered and then
started using the Infinity Gauntlet and
seize control of the universe and then
ultimately lost it to nebula and
infinity war or really the the aftermath
kind of a segue between the two so it
was more of a I guess like a prelude to
as part of warlock in the infinity watch
going into infinity war itself
The Living Tribunal basically decreed
that Adam warlock had to disperse the
stones right the stones would no longer
work in unison the gauntlet itself
wouldn't work anymore and
warlock had to basically find people who
are capable of wheeling the stones but
not using them in order to keep them
protected by in order to make sure that
nobody could reassemble them together
again would seem like a moot point
because even if they were simple nobody
could use them but people could still
use the the individual stones hence the
reason for the infinity watch and so
during that time we ended up learning in
infinity war that Thanos was in
possession of the reality stone and we
didn't initially know that we didn't
know who who warlock gave the reality
stone to but in this this little segment
here it says on to kind of fill in that
little bit of a gap because during
infinity war it was like and then Thanos
gothy and got the reality stone and that
was basically it and this is designed to
kind of fill in the gaps and essentially
say that the Thanos was the one who was
most suitable to wield it right because
only Thanos could really comprehend the
power of the reality stone and be able
to maintain that kind of discipline
right because with this stone in your
possession even your most subconscious
desires become reality you could fall
asleep and dream of like The Grudge and
then like she manifests because of the
reality stone and then kills right so
like any number of those things could
happen if Thanos is really the only guy
who could maintain it and so what this
does is it picks up you know kind of
right now in the modern day and what it
does is it kind of gives us this idea
that Adam warlock feels as though
something's off in the universe right
something just not quite right there's
some kind of imminent danger coming now
this is part and parcel to the powers of
Adam warlock in the sense that he really
is very much a sort of you know Jesus s
character in Marvel right he dies and
he's reborn over and over and over again
he could never truly be killed he'll
always end up coming back in some form
of fashion at the same time he also kind
of has this cosmic awareness and through
his experience with the soul stone is
also sort of part and parcel to the
universe now how deep reaching this goes
in exactly what this means on like a
definitive concrete level Jim Starla's
never really explained right it's almost
like the the white phoenix of the crown
and like her role in the multiverse why
she just fixed his things that are
broken whatever in the hell that means
and so with Adam warlock a lot of it's
kind of the same way it's pretty
ambiguous and it really just would've
allows Marvel and jim Starlin to kind of
have a blank slate in terms of what they
want to do with his character and and so
on and so forth but ultimately he ends
up basically traveling alongside pip
Patrol to go see Thanos right this is a
really cool moment here because with pip
the troll of course he's a long-standing
member of the infinity watch a
long-standing friend of warlock the two
of them have been together for quite
some time but traveling and seeing
Santos is really one of the first acts
of world
for a couple reasons right the first
thing is something seems off and Thanos
might know something but the other part
of this is the two of them have a very
lengthy relationship they've been on
again off again allies more so than that
there's a huge amount of respect between
the two and so as Adam warlock begins
talking to Thanos and saying like you
know there's some kind of dramatic
change that's coming there's a kind of
approaching darkness it's a cool moment
because Thanos kind of chimes in and
basically says yes you know there is a
kind of darkness approaching and he
kills Adam warlock he's like I am that
darkness and right off the bat
Thanos destroys Adam warlock like
literally incinerate his entire body if
the troll teleports the hell out he's
like man this is wild Pierce and like
bails and then Thanos is just like take
the body and dispose of it done and so
like from there you pick up on the
planet Chandalar two weeks later
Chandalar of course being the home of
the Shiar Empire with Adam warlock
basically re-emerging after this
two-week period then the question is
what in the heck is going on right like
why did Thanos kill me now Adam warlock
doesn't immediately suspect the thanasis
is of some kind of like terrible
horrible nefarious plot he believes he's
doing some pretty shady stuff but he
really wants to get more to the bottom
of things and to figure out what's
happening the problem with this is that
once pip the troll locates Thanos and
then teleports him and Adam warlock to
it Adam warlock gets blown up by a
missile he immediately gets destroyed by
a missile and the response of a nose is
like like when he's talking to his Black
Order it's like you know yes you know
Adam warlock will come back but all we
have to do is kill him three times after
that it won't matter and so what he ends
up doing is basically traveling to this
particular location this this particular
artifact looking for a kind of puzzle of
sorts and the reason why really kind of
ties into infinity siblings in the sense
of what you had in that story is you had
a future version of Thanos that
basically ended up meeting with his
younger self and what does this future
version of Fanus is doing is basically
guiding younger Thanos to some kind of
end goal but he never actually told him
what the end goal was there was just you
have to do these things that were to get
to this point where I'm at and so if a
nose isn't a lot of waste blindly
following the orders of his future self
under the idea that one he knows himself
so he trusts himself into there's gonna
be some kind of grand payoff or
something along the way
so the result of this is that once
Thanos basically accesses this
particular artifact and learns of this
kind of map of sorts you know this
particular location that it's sending
him to of course he gets back aboard his
ship and then ultimately we end up
picking up with Star Fox now Star Fox or
eros
is the brother of Thanos a lot of you
guys probably know that by now the two
of them have a very very lengthy history
infinity siblings really push that
history in that relationship to the
extreme but it's one of these things
where it's kind of like okay
eros has a couple a couple tools at his
disposal the first one is that he
basically utilized the time-traveling
technology of Kang the Conqueror and the
reason why was during the events of
infinity siblings King came to the
realization that somewhere along the
line Pharaoh's dies and when that
happens he ultimately ends up dragging
the entirety of the multiverse down with
the death of Thanos triggers a cascading
effect that brings everything to an end
prematurely so the idea was that Thanos
has to live and so I came to conquer
basically orchestrated all these
different events to who to ensure that
right so kind of a spoiler for a video
that we're gonna cover later on but the
long and short of this is that eros
hidden stolen some of the technology of
King in order to ensure that ships
something happen where Thanos engaged in
some kind of nefarious plot that eros
can go back in time and correct it the
other part of this is that a device has
basically been created this exceedingly
small there's also based on the
technology of khang that can be used to
essentially track Thanos right because
eros does not have that inherent ability
the next thing that really happens here
is a new form of manifestation from Adam
warlock usually Adam warlocks body
always kind of enters the cocoon state
and Adam warlock comes back
what is up happening here is that some
guy ends up falling off a cliff and that
person is then suddenly in case in a
cocoon and then after a two-week period
Adam warlock re-emerges right so
basically this random being was Rima T
realized into Adam warlock and then Adam
warlock returned this is not normal it
doesn't usually happen and there is in
fact a force behind everything pulling
the strings when it comes to Adam walk
there's a reason why all this is
happening with him and so what it does
from here is it basically picks up with
with eros you know ultimately tracking
down Thanos and it's kind of this cool
little little moment here because Thanos
of course is looking for eros under the
guise that his future self informed him
that eros would become very important
with regards to the various goals that
they want to achieve and so while Thanos
cannot kill eros what he has to do is
essentially find him and then keep him
contained so that he can be used at a
future point in time what that use is
going to be and the role that eros is
going to play of course we'll find out
at some point you know wound up finding
out in this story but you know from
there of course eros communicating with
Isaac Isaac of course being the computer
of Titan the one that basically kind of
governs the whole society
and so on ends up using this tracking
device puts it on fan outs and then
makes himself intangible now the way it
is that eros does this is by
manipulating time and it's a little bit
of a weird thing when it comes to the
notion of phasing in and out of reality
typically speaking the way this works is
that Marvel kind of seems to adopt this
mentality of like things travel in like
one second chunks right so like if you
were one second ahead of me I wouldn't
be able to see you but if you're a
fraction of a second ahead of me that it
means that like you're kind of this
intangible being that I cannot truly see
but you kind of exist in that same
moment I mean because that fraction of
time is so astronomically small right so
I thought that really makes any sense
you know but it's it's one of those one
of those weird things right like imagine
the time it takes you to turn your head
around and that's really what this is
equivalent to right like it takes you
you know if you if you were to snap your
head back you know it would take you
maybe like one-and-a-half seconds to do
but like in that one and a half second
period you've also got exceedingly
shorter amounts of time fractions of a
second and what Marvel's doing here
really what jim Starlin is doing here is
introducing this idea that you're his
ability to manipulate time is such that
it's not putting him seconds ahead of
Thanos is putting him fractions of a
second ahead of Thanos which means he's
essentially in the same moment that
Thanos is in but because he's kind of
out of phase meaning he's fractions of a
second ahead Thanos cannot really see
them right it's one of these weird
things right like how can you interact
with something that doesn't know you're
there
when you're technically not there it's
weird and it's really finicky I
understand if you're totally baffled and
totally confused it's just one of those
plot points and Marvel traits in order
to achieve a certain goal and so what is
up happening here is of course Adam
warlock and pip end up tracking down
Thanos and once they arrived a nose has
already left the area with and of course
they end up arriving in meeting with
eros and this is a very welcome Ally
given the history between these
characters the fact that eros has
consistently worked to thwart the
schemes of Thanos right so there are
allies in that regard and bringing to
bear this information that eros has put
a tracking device on Thanos in order to
locate him and he also has the ability
to manipulate time is a cool little
thing because it means it's basically
they're out if they choose or have the
opportunity to use it the other part of
this is that as they're talking Adam
warlock gets hit with a missile again it
just comes out of nowhere it just hits
him and then Adam warlock is of course
destroyed right that's the end of that
now pip the troll is up teleporting away
but basically is one of these things
were Pippin and Indira's have this
conversation of hey like we have our
chance to to basically combine
our information and to figure out what
this bigger picture is right it's kind
of like the Illuminati effect that using
their information that they become
greater than the sum of their parts and
so from there you end up seeing nanos
more or less being teleported away and
encountering his future self
now this future version of Thanos is
amazing looking right like he looks like
eternity with the face of mistress death
like I don't know it's kind of wild like
having him look this way it looks kind
of crazy but he looks like a cosmic
entity and so the question is how did
phantos achieve this level of power and
the way in which he gets to that point
is actually pretty solid because what
this does is it basically leads to
Thanos and his future self having this
conversation now his future self is
again pretty ambiguous here again it's
that conversation eros is going to be
important you can't kill him you have to
capture him you have to hold on to them
so on and so forth but you also have a
tracking device on you right it's like
make sure you get rid of that so eros
cannot find you that kind of a thing
ultimately because eros is aligned with
hip and because pip has the ability to
track Santos no matter where he is
doesn't really matter at all but what we
end up having here is is basically
future Thanos and what passes for
present-day Thanos concluding their
conversation and then you end up having
eros and hip Patrol of course teleport
to Thanos as location and when they get
there this planet the planet Zela I
think is what it is the last time eros
was here during the events of infinity
siblings the places are very lush and
welcome environment right it was
beautiful it was like a giant rainforest
very tropical and gorgeous something
seems to have happened here that laid
waste to the entire location and so when
the question is like have you teleported
us to the wrong place the response is no
like this entire place has basically
been totally annihilated or totally
destroyed and what you have here is that
this location has been transformed into
the realm of mistress death that's what
this is now right it's the realm of
death which is really kind of weird
because mistress death does not occupy a
physical plane here's what really exists
on any one particular physical planet
but you can't get on a spaceship and fly
to the realm of mistress death she
exists as an other dimensional entity
she literally exists in the afterlife
right so I mean I guess you could you
could get on a ship and fly to the
afterlife if the ship explodes you're
like flies into a star and you die then
sure you can get to the half your life
but you can't physically go there I mean
I guess you can if you can manipulate
dimensional barriers like Doctor Strange
or somebody like that or like fan OHS
but what it does is it switches back
over to Thanos and him basically just
sort of sitting in space and we're curva
slave and the outriders don't really
know why he's there they don't really
know what's going on like like
what they're waiting for Thanos his
response is I've been informed that at
this point there's gonna be an object or
a device passing through here and my job
is to take it and so it's kind of like
okay like we'll see how this goes which
is kind of wild and ultimately it ends
up being a comet that flies through
there
now if annals of course ends up
traveling to the comet by himself and
this is an interesting thing because
it's not just any regular comet the more
important thing to come out of this is
it that Oh States whatever this object
is and he basically says its power of a
magnitude exceeding that of the infinity
gems right so whatever this object is
it's way beyond the power of the
Infinity stone which really of course
interests that us because he's always
been on a quest to attain absolute power
the problem with this is that the device
hidden inside or the object hidden
inside this cut of this comet is not
something that can just be arbitrarily
attained right I mean you know it's not
light you know it was created and then
just dropped off on earth somewhere and
like it's just been sitting in a
convenience store it can't be one of
those things where just anybody can get
their hands on it but there's all kinds
of power protecting it you know like
this kind of cosmic energy source and so
Thanos of course starts ripping it apart
starts pulling it away and in the
process he himself begins undergoing
disintegration his body starts breaking
down the power is really more than his
physical form can handle which really
speaks volumes to how much power we're
talking about here because the kind of
energy that's needed to physically
damage Thanos is astronomical really
what happens here is once he breaks
through to the core of this comet and he
secures this object for himself then
what it appears to be is this kind of
orb of sorts now we'll find out exactly
what this is and what is what is able to
do but from there vanna's when he kind
of muses and asked the question you know
like I'm not really even sure what this
is for myself of course his future
version just kind of seems to appear to
Thanos and it says it's both a promise
and a mystery take this thing and use it
and I promise all your questions will be
answered and so what it does is it leads
to Thanos showing up to the realm of
mistress death and of course as soon as
he arrives here danos is told you cannot
be here and that's the way it usually is
right Thanos has been banned from the
realm of mistress death for quite some
time he's not really welcome here and
the thing about him showing up is he's
really kind of musing and saying like
for all the people who tell me that I
cannot come here which of you is going
to stop me right how many times have I
come in here and mistress death says I
can't be here and then she sends some
force after me and then I totally
destroy it who's gonna stop me or you
guys gonna stop me and Thanos of course
annihilates all the Hinch men and the
various people that are there to prevent
him from stay
the realm of mistress death they're all
completely destroyed and then Thanos
begins speaking directly to death
herself and says how many times have you
spurned my advances how many times have
I made my affections known to you and
you've rejected me how many times does
that happen well nevertheless if I
cannot possess then I shall become and
using this object Thanos transfers the
energy into mistress death pulls her
into himself eradicate Smith's death
entirely and danos himself becomes the
new death in the last video we basically
kind of had this idea where you
essentially had like future Thanos right
and phantos in this future looked like
eternity but whatever it was it happened
to him he seemingly became this like
omnipotent sort of character the idea
behind this is that that modern-day
Thanos is more or less being guided by
future Thanos so we'll kind of get an
answer to that question a sort of
explanation as to what's going on but
with eros the brother of pharaohs and
pit patrol trying to figure out what
Thanos is doing and then in turn trying
to find a way to defeat him they've
essentially just been following him
throughout what he's been doing right so
the idea was that Thanos and essentially
managed to find some way to acquire a
particular artifact a particular device
called the the astral regulator or the
cosmic regulator and then destroyed
mistress death and really like absorbed
her essence into himself and then became
a new death basically meaning that
Thanos now controls the realm of the
afterlife and so where he essentially
teleports away eros and pip the troll
follow him they don't know exactly where
he's going the best they can do is just
kind of jump forward through time using
their device taken by Kang the Conqueror
and then just try to understand what it
is it's happening right so this is
really just guess and check and so what
they do is jump a year into the future
and when they arrive here in the future
Galactus ship hit basically just kind of
crash-landed into this realm and when
they start inspecting they start looking
around they basically come to the
realization that Thanos has been
exceedingly busy that not only to Thanos
destroy and absorb Galactus Thanos has
also absorbed the Infinity stones he's
absorbed master order lord chaos the
stranger saiyr hate mistress love he
basically absorbed all the cosmic
entities into himself and he's been busy
now all this happened off panel I'm not
really skipping over anything we
literally go from one page to this page
he's basically just been absorbing all
the cosmic entities into himself but the
reality of where eurosam pip the troll
are is that it's just kind of like all
right so there's not a whole lot we can
do here but like in the present moment
right now there's nothing we can do to
defeat Thanos like we're
have to find a way to go back in time
and to basically keep this from
happening now here's here's the cool
thing before you bounce gemstone
emplaced I'm exceedingly smart in this
story he does it in a really really cool
way and that's one of the things that a
lot of writers kind of run into one of
the problems they run into Bendis ran
into that problem when it came to
Matthew Molloy different writers run
into time travel with different problems
and more often than not it's usually
invoked as a means to end a story jim
Starlin passes that and basically copes
with it in spectacular fashion but the
cool thing about this is that Adam
warlock you know where you end up having
pip Patrol and and and eros who
basically kind of jumped forward to
continue their journey and figuring out
what the end game of Thanos is Adam
warlock is resurrected and one of the
things that we had talked about in the
last video is it Adam warlock coming
back the way that he did was kind of
abnormal it didn't always happen that
way then he always kind of had a
particularly like a cocoon would
manifest somewhere and Adam warlock
would start to regenerate inside of it
and then ultimately he would come out
he'd make its presence known and
whatever story was going on that
required him to be in that event what
was going on here were things like there
was a reservation process that wasn't
normal right and so what this meant was
that Adam warlock didn't know entirely
what was going on and so when he
basically hops back up and really kind
of asked the question what's going on
with these changes in my resurrection
process he's met by the arrival of the
Living Tribunal and the Living Tribunal
basically says I'm the one behind all
this like I'm the reason why you're
resurrecting the way that you are now
one of the funny things about this is
that when when Adam warlock starts
asking questions like okay what's going
on like like you know why am I here that
kind of a thing The Living Tribunal says
like we're outside of reality but like
you are outside of the norm now there's
a very particular meaning to that and we
will find out what that meaning is later
on in this video but the two of them get
in a very in-depth discussion and the
reason why is because of course you have
letting Tribunal kind of like is this
multiversal overseer right so even if
the Living Tribunal can be destroyed his
job is to watch the multiverse and to
safeguard it as best he can and so
there's nothing that takes place inside
of a universe across the entirety of the
multiverse at the Liddy tribunal doesn't
know about whether or not he can stop it
is a whole different argument but he's
always aware of everything that's
happening right so multiversal awareness
it's part and parcel to his role but of
course Adam warlock also addresses the
idea that letting tribunal this version
is basically an alternate reality
version of Adam warlock those are guys
who recall that in the aftermath
of Jonathon Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and Secret Wars when the Liddy
tribunal and all the cosmic entities
were destroyed jim Starlin wrote an
infinity comic that was a tie-in to it
all more or less it was kind of a loose
event but the notion was uh the one
above all needed a new Living Tribunal
since the beyonders destroy the previous
one and so Adam warlock from an
alternate reality was made into the New
Living Tribunal so that's just kind of a
quick 30 second or a minute explanation
but as to the astral regulator and as to
how it is danos has this level of power
this all basically comes through an
explanation from the Living Tribunal and
this is a really really cool concept
introduced by by jim Starlin it's
actually built on something else right
so for the longest time when it came to
the multiverse in Marvel Jim sterling
had introduced different things like the
custodian of the multiverse and so on
and so forth but the idea here is that
we of course have an infinite number of
universes out there the question that we
always sort of asked here is what keeps
one universe from crossing over into
another what Jim Starling gives us here
is the astral regulator and what he says
is that in every single universe that
exists out there there is an astral
regulator right every universe exists
for every possibility but the let me try
beetle chimes in and says the astral
regulators are basically there to ensure
that no universe crosses over into
another this is in fact Jim starlings
adaptation of DC source wall that's more
or less what this is right the ideas of
the source wall that every universe has
its own source wall then the multiverse
has its own source wall and these are
literal barriers around universes and
around the multiverse that are designed
to prevent universes from crossing over
in other universes and multiverses from
crossing over into other multiverses jim
Starlin is essentially taking that idea
and rolling it over and basically saying
the astral regulator is designed for the
purpose of ensuring that no universe
crosses over into another but it's a
very complex network right and so
essentially Thanos taking it has kind of
destabilized things and again we'll talk
more about that here in a little bit but
what the Living Tribunal tells Adam
warlock is Thanos is working towards the
notion of not conquering the universe as
we saw him do in Infinity Gauntlet it's
not like that where he's getting the
Infinity stones slapping him on a glove
and then basically replacing eternity
that also is going for something much
much grander Thanos is trying to become
the entirety of reality and that's why
future Thanos looks the way he does he
looks like eternity because that future
version of Thanos seemingly
has achieved that level of power he is
all that is he's all
in existence and so the results of this
is is is you basically have the tribunal
tasking Adam warlock with the idea of
being the person that's going to
essentially find a way to defeat Thanos
now in truth a lot of people could
probably undertake this role but jim
Starlin chose adam warlock because the
entirety of the infinity line of store
is going from Infinity Gauntlet all the
way up to this story and in really
infinity ending ties into the idea that
there's just something unique and
special about Thanos and Adam warlock
now again Adam warlock outside the norm
will kind of cover that here in a little
bit but they are indeed holy unique
characters they are indeed characters
where for the most part yes they exist
in different realities but they stand
away from everybody else where they
stand separate from everybody else
insofar as how they come here to like
all the doctor Strange's and all the
cyclopses and all the Captain America's
and all the spider-man's and all the
Wolverines and and Phoenix forces and so
on and so forth and so what this does is
it basically leads to this idea that
Adam warlock has to do something in
order to defeat Thanos and so he's kind
of tasked by the tribunal says he's
really the only one that can seemingly
pull this off now pick him back up with
eros and pip Patrol they kind of do this
jumping around the universe right they
end up jumping into the future a little
bit further and they hop skip and around
the universe they go by earth they go by
all these different places the space
station or the celestial head of nowhere
the planet of more the planet of spartax
the brood world a scroll outpost Rigel
all these different places they've all
been destroyed by Thanos right like all
life has been totally eradicated by
Thanos like even down to the microscopic
level nothing exists there anymore and
so what this does is it picks up with a
living tribunal meeting with the one
above all now we never get to see this
in Marvel Comics we never really see
what happens when the Living Tribunal
meets with the one above all that
usually never ever ever happens and in
fact as far as I'm aware this is the
first time in Marvel Comics we've
actually gotten to see the two of them
converse in this capacity usually it's
the letting tribunals saying something
like I represent a power that's beyond
everything or whatever it is you know
he's just super Opie beyond beyond Omega
Lovelace what he is but the one above
all basically tells the Living Tribunal
what's going on in this one universe
threatens all of creation right it
threatens all things in existence what's
happened here is threatening everything
now one of the cool things that goes on
is the one above all's face shifts he
changes from one one race to another to
another to another as it was kind of a
cool theme to kind of see this melding
and switch
changing that well the one above all is
not a finite construct right like he's
just kind of this representation of
everything that exists out there and
what the one above all says is this
astral regulator is designed to regulate
the entirety of the multiverse that it's
not as small beans as a living tribunal
thought it was right the limit tribunal
looked at this and said okay so
basically Thanos taking the astral
regulator creates a cosmic imbalance and
my job is to enforce that and because
he's kind of outside the norm and he has
a level of power and so on and so forth
Adam warlock you go take care of it what
the one above all says is no you fail to
grasp the complexity of this man this is
super important because it hits at this
idea that despite all of his vaunted
power the Living Tribunal is not an
immutable all-knowing force right like
he's basically screwed up here it's
really what it is right he misjudged he
misunderstood the complexity in how
extreme the situation is what the one
above all says is the Astro regulator of
each universe yes they exist their
purpose is to keep a universe from
crossing over with another but the truth
of this is that they're all tied into a
network so what's basically gone on here
is Thanos was playing a giant game of
Jenga and he's starting to pull out the
wrong pieces and it's only a matter of
time before this whole thing comes
crashing down by taking this Astro
regulator and pulling it away from his
role and then repurposing it for the for
the reason of giving himself omnipotence
he's upset the multiversal balance right
the balance of all existence not only
that what he's doing can actually happen
he could become the entirety of reality
itself in essence the one above all now
views Thanos as a credible threat and
that's what's so crazy about this right
Thanos is at a level of power now for
the one above all is legitimately
concerned and at the end of the day it
all comes down to Adam warlock to be the
one to pull it off so that's why all
these things are really sort of crazy
here that's why it's so chaotic it's
because what we do is we basically jump
to you know present day Thanos for lack
of a better word whose absorbed all
these cosmic entities meeting with his
future self right the one that is
essentially merged with all of reality
and the whole reason behind this is the
fact that future Thanos is is fearful
the fact that somebody will figure out
what he's doing and basically stop his
younger self and that's the cool thing
here right this is Jim saw playing it
smart with reality that we would look at
this and we would say okay so if
present-day Thanos is talking to his
future self and his future self becomes
a connected to all of reality he becomes
everything in existence presumably you
know transcending the one of
The Living Tribunal in all that that
like why would he concern himself with
like making sure his younger self gets
there and the reason why is because
anybody could screw it up at any point
in time it's one thing to achieve that
role but the reality of what Thanos has
learned with regards to the multiverse
is the fact that there's an infinite
number of realities out there and
anything can happen
somebody can pop up they can be at the
right place at the right time and so
it's essentially guiding himself right
making sure that like the things that
could get in his way don't get in his
way
right that just because he ended up in
this future you know and and became this
beam doesn't mean that it's guaranteed
right like if for example he was
supposed to kill Adam warlock at a
particular point in time and he didn't
everything gets thrown off and any
number of things can cause that to
happen right any number of things can
can get in there and so what you do is
you pick up basically with eros and with
with pit patrol kind of coming to this
conclusion is it's sort of a red herring
here the way jim Starlin plays it
because it's like okay so like they're
gonna go back in time they're gonna kill
Thanos so he's a baby and basically stop
the future okay so like this is like and
there are some writers out there who
would say and this is how we in the
story guys thanks for watching you know
jim Starlin does this and before euros
can pull it off Adam warlock pops up and
says if you do that nothing will happen
it's not going to work because what's
going to happen here is things are gonna
be worse and this is really jim Starlin
tying in to everything he's done with
regards to Adam warlock and Thanos in
the entire infinity series right the
relationship between the two and when
jim Starlin was riding the old adam
warlock comics the relationship between
adam warlock and Thanos was that Thanos
had actually come to the aid of Adam
warlock
and helping Adam defeat his own future
evil counterpart The Magus you know
Magus is attempt to basically gain the
the Infinity Gauntlet for himself during
the events of infinity war Thanos being
part of warlock in the infinity watch
and basically having the reality stone
and then giving a false stone to the
Magus is what led to Magnus's defeat at
the end of the whole thing right he had
an affinity gauntlet but he wasn't
all-powerful because he didn't have all
the Infinity stones what Adam says here
is that if eros kills Thanos as a baby
then it means at each one of those
pivotal moments throughout the entirety
of the universe when Thanos helps him
defeat the Magus when Thanos gives the
Magus a false reality stone when each
one of those things takes place did it
won't happen and the future that's going
to come out of that is going to be a
future where the Magus will dominate all
of reality and put the kind of things
that Thanos did during Infinity Gauntlet
and infinity war and infinity Crusade
and the
any siblings the only kind of stuff
it'll put all that to shame and so of
course
eros basically backs off his actions and
destroying Santos as a baby and they
essentially teleport back to the modern
day or 2018 at the time this is being
done to the base of where eros is
operating at and when the question is
what do we do here you know if this plan
of killing Santos is a baby is not gonna
work then what plan do you have
and Adam warlock says this and he kills
he kills eros hip Patrol begins to freak
out but the response of Adam warlock is
according to the Living Tribunal this is
the only thing that's going to work and
so what we do is we basically jump back
to the future with with Thanos who's
essentially absorbed all these various
cosmic entities and this this you know
what we'll call them like primitive
nanos more or less in comparison to his
like ultra powerful future counterpart
but primitive Thanos is met by the
arrival of eternity and he was told by
his future version eternity and infinity
are really a couple of the last stops
that you have before this entire thing
is is taking care of right before it's
all done and so what this does is it
leads to a conflict between the two now
the cool thing about this and I love how
jim Starlin plays on this danos this is
not his first time up to bat he's done
this dance he's played this game he
understands the significance of eternity
and infinity the power that they wield
but Thanos is not concerned about either
of them because the power he possesses
in the form of the astral regulator is
way beyond the power of infinity and
eternity and so where they show up here
and they basically start using their
various abilities to try to destroy
Thanos we jump back to eros and eros of
course having been killed in the modern
day ends up travelling to the realm of
mistress death because at the time that
he died
Thanos had not killed and absorbed
mistress death yet and so what it meant
is that basically being their mistress
death is aware of the plot that Thanos
has in his attempt to like basically
show up on her doorstep and kill her at
some future point in time which kind of
makes sense being a cosmic entity that
understands the notions of like life and
death and things like that it makes
sense that she would be aware of that
and so with that being the case
she believes eros is there as a spy and
so in order to resolve the situation she
banishes
Eros from her realm that action right
there is what saves all things in
existence like that action right there
is why eros is so important and that's
why Adam warlock killed him is because
that one thing is going to essentially
be this saving grace really sorry sumit
is but transitioning back to Thanos
facing off against eternity and infinity
the reality is they're really more pomp
and circumstance here than anything
anything else they're blowing a bunch of
hot air there for all their talk of like
you're going to fall
we're going to destroy you all that kind
of stuff it's really just more pride
than anything else in the face of the
Astro regulator and the power that it
represents in the face of all these
vaunted abilities that he has infinity
and eternity fault and it's kind of
crazy because the conflict between the
two of them basically spans like all
things in existence right it expands all
of time and space across the universe
itself all time across the universe like
everything across the entirety of the
universe it's felt by them from the
universe's very beginnings all the way
to its very end the point at which it
dies like this is what we're talking
about here this is the kind of level of
power that we're discussing because
that's what these characters represent
infinity represents time and eternity
reveries in space and so to fight them
it's to fight all of time and space and
so that's why these these conflicts
between these beings literally have
shockwaves across the entirety of the
universe's history and the space the
universe occupies it's like be able to
witness an explosion all at the same
time right so like there's like an
atomic bomb that goes off or some kind
of explosion doesn't matter what it is
but like you see it and then a person
from 500 years ago sees the exact same
explosion and a person in a thousand
years sees the exact same explosion some
kind of an event across all time in
space I know it's super meta and I know
it seems kind of kind of crazy and a
little mind-bending but that's what
we're talking about when we're talking
about cosmic entities but regardless of
how hard they fight and regardless of
what tricks they pull up their sleeve in
the sense of infinity manipulating time
and trying to like age Thanos and try to
destroy Thanos and the collapse of his
physical form all that kind of stuff
none of it works and the two of them are
absorbed into themselves and when that
happens Thanos is confronted with the
with a living tribunal and the liberty
tribunal basically appears here and says
this cannot be allowed to stand this
amount of power that you have what
you've done is created an incredible
imbalance in the universe itself more so
than that you threaten the entirety of
the multiverse there's nothing to
negotiate here there's nothing for us to
talk about you Thanos are going to have
to fall and so what we do is we jump
back to eros and so eros resurrecting
basically coming back from the dead
having been banished from mistress death
this is what the Living Tribunal was
referring to you by being outside the
norm that Adam warlock can never die
Adam warlock will live forever he will
always resurrect no matter how you kill
him no matter what means it is if his
physical body is destroyed somebody
somewhere will be walking and like
they'll die they'll just kill over
from a heart attack or they'll be hit by
a bus and they'll be used as a method by
which Adam warlock returns Thanos has
been banished from the realm of mistress
death he was banished from her realm
long before this story took place right
he was banned he can never ever die like
now eros is the exact same way they
exist outside the norm because they're
immutable forces now right they're not
really on par with cosmic entities and
so far he's like they're all powerful
it's not really that way it's simply the
natural order of things which is things
are born and things die and then there's
them they're outside the norm they're
outside the natural order and so that's
the reason why why eros is so important
here is because with him and Adam
warlock working together presumably they
should be able to defeat Thanos and so
following this we pick up basically with
this massive destruction you know
they're this massive explosion seemingly
in the entirety of this system and the
defeat of the Living Tribunal and that's
why this is important is because when
you think of a fight between the Living
Tribunal and you think of the living
tribunals destruction most likely you
think of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers because that's really the only
time that we ever saw that happening
like the only time we saw before that
was during Marvel the end and it was
really more of fan of absorbing all of
reality into himself and then recreating
it again usually when you think of like
an extremely powerful being like The
Living Tribunal being destroyed you
think of like this massive explosion of
energy that would just shatter the
entirety of the multiverse it's like
it's like it's like grabbing a brick and
just throwing it into a into a glass
house right it's just it's gonna shatter
the entire thing like it's gonna it's
gonna destroy some part of the glass
house and the rest of its gonna collapse
under its own weight well that's kind of
how you you has seen that situation to
be the way this plays out though is
again it's basically just this idea of
fan oohs absorbing the Living Tribunal
into himself but that's where Thanos is
now at this moment right now Thanos has
absorbed the Linnaean Tribunal into
himself or at least that seems to be the
case now things are gonna be explained a
little bit more at a future point in
time but like fan knows basically jumps
in with his future counterpart like
starts talking to him and and
essentially his future counterpart says
you are now where I am right like we are
now where we're supposed to be you have
achieved the level of power I've wanted
you to achieve we are now one and
literally they merge into a singular
being right now this is just Jim
starlings way of rectifying the times
through the future version of Thanos
got modern-day Thanos to this level of
power and the two of them are now
occupying the same space at the same
time the truth is that they're a
singular being right they're the same
person
both cannot exist at the same time and
so they basically become this
singular person and when that happens
fano says now the real game begins now I
fan owes whom essentially the sum total
of all of reality will go forward and I
will face off against the one above all
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain and
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
link and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]